le nom du programme s'est dit mais
l'enfant sur le fleuve saint laurent
cette flotte là va être dédié non
exclusivement mais de viser emmener les
enfants du québec sur le fleuve saint
laurent
yves plante veut construire dix
embarcations d'ici l'été prochain
dix mille enfants pourront ainsi
découvrir leur fleuve avec sa faune mais
aussi ses problèmes environnementaux
arrivé par hasard au tout début de
l'aventuré etienne et nancy lemieux est
devenu aujourd'hui le premier employé
chez jeune marin urbain on est sur une
île on habite sur une île qu'on est dans
l'archipel de schlager dire des
centaines d'îles ici qu'ils ont on n'en
profite pas fait dans le contexte
montréalais les bateaux qu'on fait avec
les facteurs gros pot si c'est vraiment
pour montrer aux gens qu'il ya une vie à
vivre sur l'eau le passionné de voile a
commencé à construire ces bateaux en
2015 avec des bénévoles venus des quatre
coins de la ville il veut faire
découvrir le fleuve aux enfants en
construisant ces voiliers environ mais
il veut également faire tomber les
préjugés
je vois là encore là c'est une belge qui
hélas est un marocain qui est avec son
père qui est en amérique depuis même pas
24 heures pour la première fois de sa
vie et à mener son père sur le chantier
lire également un grand mince du niger
on est à pointe aux trembles ont
construit un voile aviron destiné aux
enfants du québec
c'est complètement improbables comme
situation
et pourtant ça existe des gens vraiment
de toutes sortes de raisons qui viennent
chez jeunes mariés robin puis juste de
pouvoir interagir avec ces gens à
l'heure de façon régulière il flanque ne
cache pas que son souhait c'est d'avoir
des jeunes marins urbain partout au
québec
il y assez de place et de gens sur le
bord du fleuve saint-laurent pour
développer l'expérience dit il en
attendant il vous attend si vous rêvez
des changes et d' aventure certains
jours ça semble une arche de noé oui
parce que là la faune est assez variée
ici robert frosi radio-canada bon gars